conducted this morning there is he is
clearly the victim of a homicide
we are trying to identify him and that
is why we are here speaking with you
right now
we are also unsure he could be he could
be a white male
he could be a hispanic male or he could
even potentially be an
asian male juvenile he's somewhere
between the ages of 8
and 12 years of age what we know
is again he has dark black hair and with
those descriptions that i've given you
anyone who is who cannot account
for their grandson their knee their i'm
sorry their nephew their grandson
or son and does not know their
whereabouts
that fits that description we urge them
to call lvmpd homicide at 828-3521
you can also reach out to crimestoppers
and you can do that anonymously
and there is reward money available in
addition you can reach out to homicide
lvmpd.com so again
very early on in the investigation i am
going to provide an
update to this case right here at 5 30
p.m tonight as this investigation
proceeds
but again please reach out we will have
that number staffed
at this point 24 hours a day as the
investigation
is ongoing i will take a couple
questions but again i'm
going to be very tight-lipped as this is
early on in the investigation
we believe he has very recently
okay so that's just the beginning of a
press conference from lieutenant ray
spencer from metro police
we heard a question i believe there from
our own vanessa murphy who is there
the news this morning this afternoon i
should say a a
boy between 8 and 12 years old a
juvenile i should say
the victim of a murder and they don't
know the child's identity yet they're
still investigating the circumstances of
this apparent homicide
we're still waiting for more details
obviously they just said it's early in
the investigation
we'll have a lot more details on this
coming up for you at 8 news now
and 8 news now dot com but a sad way to
begin
our program here on our memorial day
weekend to be sure we'll have the latest
for you coming up